what if you could go back in time and
change something you can change anything
you want what would it be dust yourself
up and move on to the next one I don't
want the next one and why do you even
care about you
you're a tall girl looking too you could
probably have any girl in this bar you
know maybe I failed to properly explain
to you the boss employee relationship
I tell you what to do and you do it you
help rich people get richer it's like
teaching fish up swim you are really
smart you'd be doing something more with
life you know it's not too late to do
something great
Martha skills are really cutting into
you I don't know what I'm doing help me
help me you're eating too much cheese
okay one winner the old-fashioned way
with your words boyfriend call you crazy
I need you apologize because I should
have told you that I had a boyfriend I
don't want to look back on this moment
and think why didn't I go after it
I don't regret time travel it is in fact
something that may become a reality but
in you consider your research man can
only handle so much failure
did you to send me back in time to a
point before she meets this guy she's
with now that she thinks she's
[Music]
I can't send you back look these
equations they're still unsolved
so unless you could solve them that you
know what the busters give up right we
can try it that's what we do
[Music]
I actually envy you you gave me the guy
that I got it's in love with the girl he
came out I hand me the guy who knows
what he wants and it's the afraid to go
after it this this lifelong quest that I
was on was actually about something else
altogether
[Music]
what are you doing here
[Music]
may the force be with you
Oh
[Music]
you
[Music]
you